bingo
bootleg cat podcast special guests in
here my guy Ron soon you know the balls
be outside every day all the way from
New York to Cali you already know the
Bronx is in the building
we everywhere yeah it's crazy uh you've
never been on my show though no nothing
right yeah no you never been on my [ __ ]
we we did the above all [ __ ] we hung out
in New York we did Corner Store brunch
make a wish
uh oh 11 11. you know what's great about
that that's the name of my nightclub
what 11 11. y'all left work see how that
work damn it uh all right you got a new
album coming that's so fat we drop
February yeah February 10th I'm gonna
live for me 2023 Vibes new energy okay
new music so we just giving them a new
type of vibe yeah what's the name it's
gonna be called It's My Tom
um because I feel like right now it's
definitely my time like after everything
I work for me and the team like we like
23 2023 that's it for greatness I ain't
gonna lie yeah you had a busy 2022 too
obviously you guys put the group project
out yeah with you on point like op Dusty
Ross wishes
um you were you were the only guy not
from Brooklyn on that huh no most
definitely yeah
and I feel like probably the only person
I ever did a table Brooklyn people yeah
in New York like that if I mean
especially like speaking from the Bronx
it's Britain Bridging the Gap right yeah
so I was probably the only person to do
that I know in a minute make a tape of
Brooklyn people and like I feel like
it's United in New York to win for me
have you been able to uh chop it up with
Dusty since he's been locked up I mean I
still send my love ownership but for me
I I didn't really get to speak to him
Europe yeah when the Thomas ride
definitely going to speak I mean I think
he knew he was going in so yeah he's
gonna be out real soon
he gonna be real soon we're gonna turn
this [ __ ] up again you know she never
stop yeah 100 man do you feel like
finally in the last like year and a half
or two people have because you kind of
bursted on the scene as a somebody who
was really funny online
um do you feel like now people are
starting to see you as like the rapper
first are you getting the respect you
think because you know when you come in
as like an Entertainer yeah you got to
kind of earn the respect of the hip-hop
community a little bit harder
I feel like now people understand
because it's a new Lane right at first
it wasn't it wasn't trending because I
like when you hear music and you hear
like where I came from I was doing skits
out first but I was still focused on
music on the side so I feel like that
time entertainment wasn't really lit in
the music business because people that
was doing drill music and things like
that had a different type of solid on me
for me you never get to see the fun side
of them so it was more serious and
that's why I feel like now you got
YouTubers and all these new people now
it's a new Lane for rappers to do [ __ ]
like that and since I was being the
first rapper to do it
it's like I opened the doors for a lot
of new artists to be theirself yeah when
we think of drill music we think of like
very serious yeah like you know
um aggressive subject matter and then
you got someone like yourself who's just
hilarious that's so fat he's not afraid
to be like himself because a lot of
rappers are afraid to be themselves man
they're like you know they got to put on
this uh facade or this character when
they're on camera and and I feel like
you've always kind of been
unapologetically yourself yeah I feel
like now it's just people
like with music it's just like a bit of
things too for me like they don't want
to like show their defense that side
because they feel like they the Fan's
not gonna like it right so it's always
like a proud thing like they don't want
to lose people you feel me like say if a
[ __ ] like always serious you're so open
side and what like right
I think that's the [ __ ] that fans like
more yeah but I feel like you're more
relatable and but in life though it's
like everybody will always be like they
don't know until you take a risk
sometimes we gotta take that risk yeah I
was willing to take that risk like to do
everything like whether it was funny and
it was crazy yeah and they doubted the
truth yeah they never thought I would be
able to do it so now for like Tom is
definitely right for me to make music
about it and and still be funny with it
too I think that's dope man who was on
the album any features yeah we
definitely got a lot of features on
there we got over six features probably
from here I got Asian duel oh my God shy
K Dougie b c blue
I got the 41 kids it's a lot of features
on there and especially like New York
oriented because I feel like
as New York
we always gonna stand out other than put
me a lot of stations for me because a
lot of States doing their thing but when
you talk about New York the drill scene
is so impeccable because you guys the
people from different size that's doing
drill like r b you got Alicia Keys
everybody that's doing drill Kanye West
so I feel like me going back to New York
and
circling to do songs with these people
and show that we still
here how crazy is it to hear like Alicia
Keys singing over a drill beat like that
shit's kind of crazy right I said
growing you are yeah about a day like
the most new artist says the more is new
sign for the drill genre
it's always gonna grow It's Gonna Last
too would you consider Fabio to kind of
be like the like one of the Godfathers
of this New York drill [ __ ] because I
feel like he was kind of one of the
first guy even before Pop I feel like he
kind of was the guy who like nationally
was making noise I mean crank me if I'm
wrong yeah I'll give him his flowers you
know he definitely put on for for a lot
of people for me especially in New York
because he did a lot of features you are
so
um uh explain to me uh well first of all
kudos to you K flock and Dougie B for
um being uh man enough to kind of put
issues aside before things get out of
hand and get you know guys I thought
that was a dope thing to see because a
lot of artists we don't see people
squashing beef we see somebody on you
know especially in New York people are
losing their lives left and right man so
I thought that was a amazing considering
you guys are off in the Bronx and uh I
feel like the Bronx
in the drill scene is is not as you know
uh big as Guys from Brooklyn I mean you
guys are kind of like you know waving
that flag and and to be on as a united
front I think that's important um what
was behind you guys you know burying the
hatchet and squashing the beef
I feel like
sometimes like this is the
miscommunication yeah most of the time
most of the time like miscommunication
like
I met people in person like for me like
when I met Dougie B we talked in person
for me so it's like
those type of vows you got to see
because a lot of times it would be the
internet you got the internet in between
people and always custom situation like
even with like you go back to like like
50s who probably mad [ __ ] going on with
the blows all types of [ __ ] but then you
meet people and sit down it's different
for me so I feel like I sit down with
certain people and see the bigger
picture you heard so you guys just kind
of sat down and were like hey what are
we doing like not yeah like for me even
even with my man he said collaborable
competition like that's a quote that I'm
always gonna
I feel like that's gonna stand out to me
because it's like at the end of the day
when you compete with people it's never
gonna last because when you collab with
them you can make sense yeah let's get
some more there's more money in
collabing than there is in beefing yeah
and that's why I feel like I could be
the artist to do that too because it's
like I don't have beef with anybody like
I don't make diss tracks I don't make
the type of music where people feel like
I gotta choose a sign so when I bring
all these people together it's gonna
make sense yeah what up we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family over at my bookie
that's right with lots going on in
basketball right now Lots going on in
the NFL playoffs are about to start
Super Bowls coming up so much to gamble
on let's win some money go to my bookie
right now if you sign up for a new
account mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview
yeah I do think that like you do stand
out in that um way amongst your peers
who make drill music is as to where a
lot of your music's subject matter isn't
necessarily
uh derived in killing [ __ ] and
it's like you put me in Greener like my
music is still gonna make people
adrenaline of course of course you got
so much energy
you can still go crazy to my music but
it's not necessarily to the point where
you gotta for me go out the window for
that you know you can still get crazy do
you feel like
um in general some of the guys in the
drill scene are kind of maturing because
you know there has been people who have
lost their lives not anybody associated
with you per se but I just mean in terms
of like
you know now that you got guys like the
uh the new mayor of New York talking
about banning drill music and certain
radio stations saying we won't play
certain drill music do you feel like
collectively the scene is starting to
kind of realize like there's more money
if we don't hurt each other and if we
kind of just yeah you don't think so I
just feel like [ __ ] is wiping
themselves out yeah [ __ ] is [ __ ] is
good because people gotta understand
like when you worry about little [ __ ]
you not gonna laugh out here you heard
so I feel like
as the people that's that's open to
douche right now is the people that's
still here you are supposed to be new
artists so I feel like the drill scene
is not getting clear it's just people
not lasting so it's not that much people
rapping on that right I mean so I'm just
one of the few to be still doing this
because I feel like I stay in my Lane I
don't gotta feed into the negativity so
it's like oh in this in this Lane you
gotta just know how to last you know
have you had a big homie in the rap game
in New York just put his arm around you
give you some game but yo I got good
management and I got a good family no
you do have great management shout out
to my guy Bo good good management I mean
like any any OG rappers like a fat Joe
or like a noise like he's just watching
growing up no no no like somebody who
you who co-signed
reached out you know what you know what
it is when you do it independently you
learn more so it's like me being an
independent artist and just teaming up
with certain different labels it's like
it's all this is that's doing [ __ ] but
they never get the experience to be here
his own so when your hands on [ __ ] you
get to see so I'm learning everything so
a lot of these artists don't know so I
get to talk to them and see what I could
do you know like I mean you obviously
um you're I was gonna say like you are
very uh in terms of your your ceiling I
feel like it's like super stardom
because of your personality would you
ever consider acting doing movies [ __ ]
like that nah most definitely I ain't go
a lot like when the time is right when
it makes sense I'm definitely going to
do that like I'm just waiting for the
opportunity hell yeah that'd be crazy
without a TV show or some [ __ ] I I own
TV show for me be sending girls backs
it'll go viral like I have my own shoes
yo what is the one skit you've done that
you got the most backlash about
um or negative feedback or people like
yo what the [ __ ] are you doing because
you've had some wild skits he probably
the news the whole channel is like I
feel like oh you got the bootleg coming
up just slide that thing back there you
go it's right on yeah so now I feel like
the whole challenge because you got some
people that I haven't seen this so what
is it yeah it's called the Horse
challenge well I'm sitting on girls
backs because I don't got a permit or a
license so when I sit on a girl back and
still Transportation wait wait sir and
she like she like travels for you so
she's like your horse she's my horse for
me so now it's the horseback challenge
but I feel like that's that's something
that people gotta understand you for me
because you know you guys that's that's
my kind of humor
maybe for the wrong reasons but I'm with
it yeah it is for me that's why it's
like for me it's however you look at it
but how much you weigh like a buck buck
50 Buck 55 171
68 I go along
probably right now I don't know I
definitely gotta check the horseback
challenge yeah I'm getting on any girl
back and she would let me I love that a
lot of girls got strong backs that I
mean yeah are you are you single at this
point in time Ron
um
I'm not gonna say I'm single I'm having
fun you're having fun I'm having fun
that's important I'm young you are young
[ __ ] I have fun I don't gotta settle uh
how much music are you currently sitting
on
outside of the album we know the album's
coming how many songs is that and then
I'm sure you got hard drives full of
[ __ ] yo every time I go to the studio
I'll do it soon
so you got a lot of music literally
every time of my life that I went to a
studio I did a song like if it was a
Studio's book for like me yeah I did it
soon so I feel like that's like like
over a thousand
over a thousands what's your writing
process do you punch in or do you write
down
I freestyle so you're doing like you do
line by line yes most majority of time I
just come up with the hook okay I come
up with a hook I try to make it catchy
like right sometimes it depends on the
beat too yeah I mean like sometimes it
could be a hit or miss because music is
not gonna always be 100 so like I feel
like we're beats if they beat match my
personality is gonna be a hit
so it's gonna be natural I go in the
booth I make a hug that [ __ ] that ass
boat is natural bro I swear to God yeah
I feel like you do have a you do have a
um
a proclivity for hooks for sure I fly
challenge go to the fans for me yeah
even with grobo what they're gonna say
even with Wawa the remix I feel like
that remix got so much views you would
have thoughts the original one right for
me like shout out to the skilly band for
me everybody that did they think on the
remix but I had the best remix I didn't
go a lot like you don't make the
catchiest songs you know what's crazy is
the uh first time I ever see someone
smoke a spliff in my life was when I saw
you do it no because that's some real
like East Coast [ __ ] it was in bubble no
backwards I saw you like rolling a
cigarette it was weed with like the leaf
chopped up in it what the [ __ ] these
Bronx ass [ __ ] nah yeah that's
the move I go a lot of bro like that's
how I feel like you got to smoke out
here because
you can control your blood like I feel
like with a backwood you can't even
control how much do you have a paper
right and then you put the weed in it
and then you chop up the grab a leaf I
mean it should come up already like
chopped up okay okay so then so you go
to the store and there's just a chopped
grovel if you buy yeah and then you
sprinkle that in roll it up yeah that
should go crazy I go live so it's like
50 cigarette 50 blunt Ah that's that's
from like a different burrow inside like
I'm full of Bronx I smoke got some
splits 90 90 weed ten percent guava yeah
okay but I'll put the grub in the right
place nice
you know like
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to uh stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah blue chill gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the Bluetooth
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not going to perform
it's not it's not going to perform how
you'd like it to but you know how it
will perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview
I mean this is what's kind of crazy
about New York now because the first
time I met you was like the day after it
became legal it was like the day right
Cyrus weren't we out there like the day
it happened that was crazy
so we I didn't get to really see like
I just went back and that [ __ ] is the
Wild Wild West like you go to the
[ __ ] the bodega and there's [ __ ] a
jar of weed behind the [ __ ] counter
and they're selling AIDS out of like
every random corner store in New York
City if there's [ __ ] tables full of
that [ __ ] at the park like yo we're in
the middle of an interview bro yo that
was hard
it's a girl and now yo if y'all come get
you hey send your boy out
the girl like the [ __ ] pulled up yeah
are you up for that interview the Cali
puss has slid now yeah but what you were
saying I'm saying that though the weed
is everywhere in New York nah yeah
[ __ ] is getting weed anywhere but it's
every even uh mushrooms is everywhere
yeah why'd you hear about mushrooms
though why what's up though the shrooms
is everything what's up like that's like
accessible now yeah in New York City
it's legal
snooze is legal bro I don't know I just
know they were selling them why I keep I
feel like everybody's taking shrooms
this year
like it's so trending right now like
somebody like I feel like I get asked
the secrets have you tried any more nah
why not because I just smoke weed and I
drink a little bit look at like if I'm
lit like so you won't do like heroin
bug it nah Ron we can't shoot up after
this no do some real 70s
but it's crazy little you want to smoke
some mac a lot of these rappers probably
be doing this [ __ ] like sure these
[ __ ]
these rappers definitely be coked out of
their [ __ ] brain I don't know about
heroin I don't know anybody who's done
heroin yeah I never met a person that
did that most rappers do a lot of
cocaine yeah I do a lot of whatever keep
them going you feel me now
you can't condone that [ __ ] stay away
stay away from the drugs cause listen
they're killing our young fans they're
killing our young people stop it random
question Ron have you ever but have you
ever paid for sex
I mean if you want to talk about like
like necessarily like Uber's food like
that's what I can see have you ever been
have you ever not nice directly you've
never went to a rub and tug you talk
about a spot like yes no you never
gotten a massage you never got rubbed
down no I did I did right but it was
free
so you might have paid for a massage
of course there was a happy ending happy
ending of course yeah of course nice how
old was the lady was she like an old
Asian lady
she's probably 37. but that was it that
was when I was like 19.
how much music are you releasing this
year just I mean we got the new project
February 10th yeah that that's it will
have a close one
are you are you like spinning the block
pretty soon are you gonna let it live
for a while what are you doing I mean
like
I'm gonna let that [ __ ] marinate because
they all hits like other songs with mad
people right
foreign
[Music]
who do you got is the greatest I mean
you you from a very legendary Borough
it's literally where hip-hop started the
birthplace of hip-hop it's the Bronx
who's in your top five Bronx MCS of all
time you can't say yourself you can't
say yourself MCS like yeah I can't even
think about it from the bones that's too
old Big Pun fat Fat Joe I could say a
fat Joe Big Pun who I'm gonna say
like yo Max who we who from the Bronx is
rapping back then I don't know just ever
because I was listening to 50 like
that's Queens like I won't be able I'm
gonna give it a bug I was on the bunks
but when I was growing up I'm listening
to 50
I'm listening to [ __ ]
fabulous Jay-Z lots of Brooklyn and
Queens Brooklyn Queens like you for me
of course Fat Joe yeah
shout out to Joey crap who Joey crack
they call him Joey crack Joey cracked
him yeah oh I bet no I mean yeah Don
Cartagena man I mean listen Fat Joe
instrumental that's why I did the weed
challenge too bro I made a challenge to
his instrumental he I know you see that
[Music]
I don't know
[Music]
Hood though
he came to my hood hey I came to your
hood yeah you came here you came to Mama
got a chopped cheese I ain't gonna lie
but he came to my hood he did like a I
think he was like yo yo man we came
to call out you remember
he did though he did saying I forgot
gang took a pic with him though wow that
was before yo when we were hanging out
in your area we were just like hanging
out in some random Courtyard yeah for
like houses two hours and I was like my
boy's from the Bronx and I dropped at my
location he's like bro you are in the
middle of the [ __ ] over there
cardi B's up there too best Bronx
rappers right I mean she's been putting
on for sure yeah cardi B you got ice
spice ice ice spices from the Bronx I'm
not sure we could put her any best
rapper discussion she's a rapper though
Naya she's doing her thing though she's
doing her thing
it's mad new people right now
coming from the bones
yeah you know what that is yeah yeah
he's on fire he's on fire yeah he's on
fire right now I didn't even know he's
from the Bronx
he's selling out hella sure
he's like a kid too right here too but
yeah
yeah you guys are killing it man
huh
oh KRS one of course KRS one
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait Ron you don't know who cares
sound of the police yeah you know this
is probably sibling boogie down
Productions now we're not bumping them
into a world
like [ __ ] that a bucket like Karis one's
one of the greatest rappers of all time
now in fact shout out to kills one I'll
listen to two people never in your
[ __ ] life listen to KRS one that's
how I do not one [ __ ] Aretha Franklin
you Martha Stewart doesn't make music
Ron who mother she's a she cooks on TV
and steals money
she's on TV with Snoop that's messed up
one song you've ever listened to in your
life
[Laughter]
you told me they were so like I know
that's fine I named the song for you I
know that song
like what other soon they made like it
was in movies though if it was the South
Bronx the South South Bronx I know that
was from
that stone that's boogie down
Productions that's KRS one hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at hardean that's
right Hardin Las Vegas the craziest
dispensary in the world the number one
dispensary in the United States let
alone in Las Vegas all right maybe
you're hitting Vegas with your friends
your girlfriends whatever maybe it's a
bachelor party whatever's going on
you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell them
I sent you they got the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis I've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life the pre-rolls
the cartridges the Edibles the flower
all top notch all the best the bud
tenders are so friendly it smells great
it smells so good inside a Jardine that
they have their own Harding signature
scent candle
see I sniffed that and I just think of
Las Vegas and picking up some amazing
weed all right so go follow them right
now Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot
him a follow get all the details you
need you can get you some of this fly
ass Harding merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview yo
you don't even know
the [ __ ] that made on hip hop for the
bones you know how he had a crates yeah
my dad was holding trees he was holding
the crates at that time when he probably
was freestyling back then when like
hip-hop was invented your dad was there
apostles did are you telling me your dad
invented hip-hop he was in that
generation he was he was I'm influenced
by hip-hop so your dad was there with
like cool herc and all that [ __ ] my dad
was holding him back oh my daughter look
on my daughter tonight
my dad was he knew who hurted wow they
knew each other well look at you you're
a [ __ ] hey he lived on that block you
were born for this [ __ ] my dad lived on
that block when he was younger
I swear to God I was born I don't
believe you've ever listened to KRS but
I believe this my pop was in a query
freestyling
freestyle that I'm already rapping wow
I'm trying to show you I'm trying to
show you bro
do you ever listen to uh any of the UK
[ __ ]
anything like y'all Focus Millions right
bust Millions okay me and him probably
gonna do something for him
I was talking to him on Facebook I'm
such a fake like I got a song with
beauty you know Beauty no no you're from
UK the only guy that I know means I
think I know uh Central C and that's
about it yeah yeah that's right now yeah
I mean
yo those your cat I'm trying to indulge
in that yeah
I'm about to go to UK
I just got my password oh it's okay now
you're about to go to Toronto I'm about
to go everywhere do y'all are you
allowed back at rolling loud yet I don't
know now that you guys squashed the
thing I feel like you guys should each
like y'all should come out together at
the next rolling loud it's kind of
[ __ ] up that in New York the cops like
are [ __ ] blocking all the rappers yo
they bugging it ain't even rolling loud
that's doing it it's the [ __ ] cops
right yeah is it Jersey or is it the
NYPD no I go live bro I don't know what
it is bro
I ain't do nothing
you're a pretty positive guy yeah I
don't do nothing but I always establish
the trouble I don't condone violence you
feel me bro I made music for the kids
you don't do heroin no
um
no of course
yo I I go loud let me tell you I I
should leave high once in life that's
like liquid heroin I've never done it
yeah I believe that's why I heard so
that's how I say right I sit the Wild
Ones because I took the walk to Poland
yeah
you never took the walk to Poland
is that a little yachty song yeah that's
what I'm saying he took the walk to Polo
I took the walk to my block I ain't I
ain't even go to Poland I haven't been
to Poland I feel like it's racist that
you would assume I've been to Poland no
I'm just saying Lil yachty did I don't
know did you I didn't know uh any
anybody you want to work with this year
that you haven't worked with yet man I
need a Justin Bieber feature I like that
like what's up and I need a
like
like that's it yeah have you tried to
slide in ice spices DMS at least
maybe take her for a trip talk about
that you should take her for a trap
cheese
date yo I ain't gonna lie you take how
much time she's dead
I spice is here right now
I got glitch houses right not in L.A
yeah
you got good tacos tacos breakfast
like I'm going to La for good weed
that's a I do feel like the weed in New
York is like hit or miss because it's so
available now that it's just everywhere
nice sometimes y'all be getting [ __ ]
thinking of some design it's just like
okay no I'm not saying you I mean I know
I know but [ __ ] [ __ ] don't be smoking
right out here man
these [ __ ] in New York you're they
gotta they gotta come to us every and
everyone just got a pound of weed in in
New York now just like yo you want an
eighth hold on everybody getting weed
like where you from yeah I smoke zotto I
got all the bootleg [ __ ] weed bags at
the bodegas you could buy the [ __ ]
empty bag you keep [ __ ] with the mic
thing Jesus Christ
I don't know why I was doing that I
don't know it's because you keep doing
this
you're picking you know you did that on
purpose you keep picking the mic up and
twirling it around and it's
like it's just there you keep spinning
it around there like I want to grab I'm
about to grab this [ __ ] like I'm gonna
just have it you can still hear me
yeah I bet now you know what it is oh no
it's just dead I feel like I'm in the
studio like I'm about to rap so when I
rap I always fix the mic like I'm about
to you feel me because you know the mic
be shorter than me yeah I always bring
it up so I just want to hey we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right the
most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board you know what I mean we
get to put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview well listen man yeah
your new album comes out February 10th
it's 12 records
six features-ish right about six
um hopefully I spice responds to your DM
soon enough so you can get in a ribs
um
we need to set up the KRS one feature
oh okay I was white yo Keith Murray
that was random
are you just naming old rappers
of course yeah
yeah what why are you naming Keith hey
sit down and tell me why Bo wants you to
tell me about Keith Murray what happened
with Keith Murray bro I heard you're
gonna evaluate though he is going viral
like I'm just hear this [ __ ] named gig
like I go live bro do you know anything
about him are you from the Bronx right
easy oh it's Keith Murray from the Bronx
the most beautifulest thing in the world
I don't think he's from the Bronx
is he from the Bronx he's not somebody
say he's from the bones
yeah we did it no we did an interview in
Atlanta right it was like Keith Murray
from the bones I think like who that
Long Island buddy
Suffolk
he gassed it um you know who is from the
Bronx oh Jerry Springer no you're not I
know he's not I'm [ __ ] I'm about to
say cause yo yo between me you I keep
seeing him yo boo act like you don't
know yo bro remember
yo I keep seeing Jerry Springer why like
like he won't ever see like I thought
you meant like you keep seeing him in
your dreams
so he do game shows he do man he's like
a judge yeah he did he is a judge on TV
you do everything like this thing it's
crazy
all right well Liz Ron suno we
appreciate you pulling up man yo bro
thank you for having me you already know
go get the new album February 10th box
man